I don't think I would have found myself  in a happy and healthy relationship had  I not gonna work on myself first  eet sat down with this star Mandy Moore  at the special friendsgiving event she  hosted with American Express the newly  engaged actress revealed her wedding-day  wish list for her big day with fiance  Taylor goldsmith three must-haves you  definitely want to have in the wedding  what would they be I think we want to  have like a friend officiate  so feeling like that that connection  with our friends and our friend group  and having them feel a part of it I  think I want to maybe do it at our home  like do it very privately Oh maybe have  music I want music to be an important  thread throughout so maybe find a way to  incorporate Taylor or some of our  musician friends or something just make  it feel very much like us and like a  slightly more elevated like house party  or something  nothing fancy yeah  [Music]  you  [Music]